según el fiscal de la Corte Penal
Internacional este acuerdo detalla la
asistencia técnica y la asesoría que
brindarán al Estado venezolano para
eventuales reformas al sistema de
Justicia que el objetivo es que haya más
justicia y una paz sostenible en
Venezuela Nicolás Maduro dijo además que
la instalación de una oficina de la
Fiscalía de la Corte Penal Internacional
en territorio venezolano generará un
impacto favorable y que las puertas de
Venezuela están abiertas al mundo para
que se conozca la verdad por encima de
lo que su juicio son mentiras y
manipulaciones difundidas a través de
los medios de comunicación pero Qué
implicaciones tendrá esta oficina
organizaciones no gubernamentales han
insistido en aclarar que esta oficina no
va a recibir denuncias directas por
parte de las víctimas y que no tiene una
relación directa con la investigación
que se adelanta para determinar si en
Venezuela se han cometido crímenes de
lesa humanidad bajo la administración de
Nicolás maduro pero que es positivo que
haya personal y funcionarios de la
Fiscalía de la Corte Penal Internacional
en Venezuela que puedan conocer de
primera mano la realidad del país y que
hagan un seguimiento a estos casos de
denuncias de violaciones a derechos
humanos recordemos que hace
aproximadamente un mes la fiscalía de la
cpi recibió cerca de 8.900 testimonios
de personas que se consideran Víctimas
de abuso por parte del Estado antes de
abandonar Venezuela el fiscal de la
Corte Penal Internacional karincam dijo
que esperaba regresar pronto y más
seguido al país